found now for a very special edition of
the Dhanbad Gino news explosion instead
of looking at the big news of the past
week our favorite former New York City
policeman is here to list his favorite
stories of what has been a remarkably
bizarre 2020 Democratic campaign Dan
bungee no ladies and gentlemen joins us
tonight
dan good to see you yeah Tucker I had to
think hard about this one because there
were so many comical Democrat stories up
to this cycle so I distilled them down
to four here's number four this one's
remember that old uh party cartoon you
know sharing is caring
not in all cases bado decided orbit Oh
as you appropriately call him Robert
Francis to go to the dentist and share
with the entire country his dental visit
the campaign tucker has been a cavity
ever since he got enough body cavity
down hale over after that I don't blame
the dentist I blame bado bado sometimes
sharing is it Cara Lee right Tucker
swell but it's also it was not all
narcissism is rewarded it turns out
which is a great message like it's
really a meeting of the door sisters
looking at the water right he thinks
it's so important that people want to
see his dental visit we don't but thanks
for trying beta we appreciate it
all right Story number three the zero
percent or was it an event that the
concept is zero is it the babylonians or
the absence of value altogether right
well that is SWA well and de Blasio are
two absolutely atrocious politicians I
have a hard time discerning which one is
worse but at least one of them Tucker at
least sois well was smart enough to get
out while he could still preserve the
remnants of his reputation de Blasio he
has no such concerns that all he's
already ruled that there's no reputation
left so there goes the zero percent errs
number two Cibola harris can't seem to
decide what she want to be she flipped
she flops he flips again she did the old
540 180 360 540 did it on health care
can't decide if she wants to be tough on
crime loose on crime she doesn't get it
thank god tulsi gabbard called her out
in the last debate we saw that that
didn't look great
and nobody's won yeah what Joe Biden
apologizes for being Joe Biden but Joe
Biden can't seem to figure out who Joe
Biden is I had a write down a list Joe
Biden's taken opposing positions on
health care on Democratic senators he
worked with on the Hyde Amendment on
busing apologized it for Joe Biden but
isn't even over Joe Biden is it's sad
but in your hands it's also deeply
amusing Deborah Gina great to see you
thank you for that